[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau c'est huit invités voici les
titres après avoir été certifié
biologique
en mai dernier le lait de la ferme de
rambouillet sera maintenant transformer
nous étions présents lors de
l'inauguration de ce nouvel atelier de
transformation nous avons interviewé
roland de long le directeur de la
structure
mais on débute ce 7,8 invité avec la
primaire de la gauche en 2010 est le
scénario aurait pu être simple pour le
ps il y avait un chef le président
sortant et tout le monde devait
s'aligner derrière lui seulement le
président de la république a renoncé et
les cartes de la primaire de la gauche
sont donc rebattues aujourd'hui en
candidat nous avons manuel valls vincent
peillon gérard filoche benoît hamon et
aux harengs et plein d'autres et j'en
passe et nous avons aussi maxime legrand
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
poissy que nous recevons ce soir à 41
ans ce chef d'entreprise présente ses
propositions basé sur le triptyque
éducation emploi et entreprises
bonsoir monsieur bonsoir alors vous en
rêviez tous les matins
l'élection présidentielle où vous
cherchez un poste à ni l'un ni l'autre
je suis un chef d'entreprise de 41 ans
j'ai la chance d'être né à poissy
d'avoir grandi à poissy d'avoir fait mon
collège et mon lycée à poissy puis après
d'avoir fait sciences po et normale sup
et d'avoir choisi d'être entrepreneur
alors je suis pas à la recherche d'un
poste ni d'un ministère j'ai envie que
mes idées en matière d'éducation
d'emploi d'entreprises ce qui me paraît
être la priorité pour notre pays est
bien triomphe dans le cadre de cette
primaire il soit au service des français
vous êtes profondément de gauche est ce
que vous trouvez pas qu'aujourd'hui la
gauche est vraiment divisée et que là
vous venez ajouter à cette division
alors la gauche aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de vous dire quel numéro de téléphone
parce que c'est pas la gauche c'est
aujourd'hui les gauches le multiples
gauche et pas la gauche et les gauches
qui pour nombreux d'entre elles n'ont
strictement rien à voir
pour vincent peillon lisez présenté
dimanche soir donc hier à la primaire de
la gauche
vous en pensez quoi vincent peillon a
défini sa candidature comme le centre de
gravité le point g si j'ose dire deux du
parti socialiste
j'ai vraiment pas l'impression que c'est
ce qui intéresse les français
aujourd'hui de savoir quel est le centre
de gravité du parti socialiste et deux
qu'il en ait donc pour vous il n'y a
aucun candidat aujourd'hui qui a grâce à
vos yeux
moi je suis pas dans les débats de
personnes de savoir qui au centre qui
est à gauche qui est à droite du parti
socialiste c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse
ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui va
permettre à la france de se relever et
aux français d'avoir un avenir différent
en matière d'éducation d'emploi et
d'entreprises le reste ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt ni pour moi ni pour
les français juste derrière questions
sur la politique politicienne qu'est-ce
qui a été le déclencheur pour vous
le déclencheur pour moi c'est que en
tant que chef d'entreprise qui à paris
londres new york qui considère par
ailleurs que l'éducation elle doit être
centrale
vous êtes d'accord avec moi cette
éducation le paquet doit être mis sur
l'éducation en matière de d'économies en
matière de justice sociale en matière de
république
ça doit être central cette question de
l'éducation c'est ça ma préoccupation
c'est concrètement
moi je suis libre je suis indépendant ma
feuille de paye à la fin du mois ne
dépend pas d'un ministère ne dépend pas
d'un conseil régional ne dépend pas du
parti socialiste donc je souhaite que
mes idées elle avance c'est ça m'a
compliqué mais on va passer à votre
programme et en plus vous parler
d'éducation donc ça tombe très bien où
vous comptez si vous êtes élu président
de la république fusionner les
ministères de l'éducation de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
de la formation professionnelle et de
l'emploi
est ce que ça fait pas beaucoup et est
ce que ce grand ministère va pas manquer
de clarté
ah non il va pas manquer de clarté on va
enfin s'occuper du sujet central
c'est-à-dire l'élève l'étudiant et puis
demain la personne qui va s'insérer où
la personne qui doit se réinsérer
moi je souhaite qu'on mette le paquet en
matière de créativité d'innovation
pédagogique
je souhaite que tous les enfants de ce
pays aient les mêmes droits en matière
d'éducation
après les histoires de fiscalité de
donner des revenus complémentaires des
revenus de solidarité c'est de la
foutaise
alors ça se déroule commencé quelques
c'est un agent qui suivra une centaine
d'enfants on va dire jusqu'à jusqu'à sa
majorité
ça veut dire qu'au niveau central et
bien on craque un ministère qui se
préoccupe de cette question éducation
emploi insertion professionnelle
orientation
on met le paquet sur l'orientation et ça
veut dire qu'on a une déclinaison locale
ou une même personne
en effet qu'il soit petit grand chômeurs
salariés plein de situations et bien
puisse réellement s'en occupe et qu'il
est une personne en face de lui ça
suffit d'être un numéro dans ce pays
donc si je comprends bien il va avoir
quand même des fonctionnaires qui ne
seront pas reconduits ah non je pouvais
à payet après son poste non je pense
qu'il va y avoir des fonctionnaires qui
vont avoir enfin un boulot intéressant
c'est à dire qu'ils vont s'occuper de la
personne en matière d'orientations en
matière d'éducation en matière
d'insertion en matière de formation
professionnelle c'est à dire qu'ils vont
avoir un job à 360° et s'occuper des
personnes c'est pas la question de
de savoir si on va virer ou pas des
fonctionnaires on va faire mieux
c'est ça le sujet on va s'occuper mieux
des personnes pour qui le plus problème
d'insertion
alors vous proposez aussi une
exonération totale des cotisations et
charges aux pme tpe pour chaque embauche
d'un jeune diplômé ou d'un demandeur
d'emploi
oui vous avez oublié une partie de la
mesure d'offres d'emploi dès lors où
celui ci sera rémunéré 25 % au-dessus du
smic je fais bien mon travail alors la
question allait à bien votre travail la
question elle est simple est-ce que ça
sap a été déjà plus ou moins fait avec
le 6e ou encore le pacte de
responsabilité
non ça a été fait ni avec le cic eux ni
avec le pacte de stabilité mes de
solidarité entre lui même pendant les
propositions dit révolutionnaire d'
emmanuel macron quel est le sujet c'est
le deal moi je suis chef d'entreprise
donc toujours je cherche un win win et
un deal est là le dit c'est quoi c'est
de dire je suis ministre de imaginons de
l'économie de main franche préférait
être président de la république et je
dis aux chefs d'entreprise aux tpe pme
je leur dis les gars je vous exonère de
cotisations patronales totalement en
contrepartie vous donner plus de pouvoir
d'achat aux salariés et pas un euro par
jour comme le propose emmanuel macron
mais concrètement on remonte le smic de
25% ça veut dire que quelqu'un qui est
normalement à 1300 euros et qui coûte
2500 euros à l'entreprise
il sera à 1700 euros et il coûtera 1700
euros à l'entreprise c'est à dire sur du
social libérale non quand même on est on
est sur le win win
entre tout le monde c'est-à-dire des
solutions et cette solution n'a jamais
été proposé c'est l'intérêt d'une
candidature
on a baissé des charges des heures des
zones à b et c on n'a pas remonté le
pouvoir d achat des salariés
ok mais on est donc dans la
confrontation entre patronat et
syndicats c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui les
électeurs de gauche c'est ce qu'ils
souhaitent ça quand même posé pas mal de
problèmes et ce qui est dit c'est que
les patrons n'ont pas joué je n'a pas de
recruter derrière là il ya un vrai deal
qui se fait entre le ministre et les tpe
pme
vous remarquerez que je vous parle pas
des grandes entreprises et j'ai rien
contre les grandes entreprises vous
parle des tpe pme
il ya un vrai deal c'est la différence
avec ce qui s'est fait avant c'est à
dire on demande une remontée
du smic tpe pme et en contrepartie il ya
une exonération de cotisations
patronales
et s'il n'y a pas de remontée du smic 1
c'est pas les fodil de la mandature
précédente
si on a pas et bien il y aura pas
d'exonération de cotisations patronales
c'est simple c'est clair c'est efficace
en tout cas vous avez expliqué votre
idée on passe à la troisième idée très
rapidement enfin une parmi tant d'autres
un jeu précise donc pour des jeunes
post-bac les étudiants auront droit à un
crédit c'est-à-dire de 10000 euros
maximum nos à ma question pour leurs
études ou pour voyager
ma question est simple qu'ils payent à
vous savez moi ma candidature aller
simple elle vient de mon expérience
professionnelle ou ma boîte aller à
paris londres et new york et à londres
au royaume uni eh bien les frais de
scolarité sont dix mille euros à peu
près ce qui permet d'avoir des
universités qui sont dans les meilleures
mondiales et en contrepartie
l'université accorde un prêt à
l'étudiant de 10000 euros et vous savez
ce que ça fait ça fait l'université
alors envie de récupérer son argent et
elle s'occupe de l'insertion
professionnelle de ses étudiants
alors qu'ils payent c'est un emprunt et
bien je vous remercie et en tout cas
vous avez pu défendre vos idées et
j'espère que vous serez candidat à la
primaire de la gauche et je vous
remercie
l'agroécologie fait son chemin la
bergerie nationale après avoir été
certifié biologique en mai dernier le
lait de la ferme de rambouillet sera
maintenant transformer nous avons
profité de l'inauguration de ce nouvel
atelier pour interviewer roland de long
le directeur de la structure
nous on dit plus la production du lait
est ancienne
ce qui a changé cette année c'est la
conduite du troupeau puisque nous
respectons maintenant les principes de
l'agro écologie et nous sommes
labellisés agriculture biologique donc
dans ce cadre là on a réfléchi aussi à
la commercialisation de nos produits
puisque c'est bien de produire un lait
de qualité en lait biologique mais il
faut aussi avoir des circuits qui
permettent de commercialiser à proximité
est transformé à proximité entre les
enlevant le lait aux deux
transformateurs qui se sont installés
sur place donc à un prix identique est
différente de la coopérative
mais comme c'est un circuit de proximité
on est en contact direct avec eux on a
un retour aussi immédiat sur la qualité
du lait puisque le lait est un produit
bien qu'il ya une qualité qui peut
varier en agriculture biologique que
c'est intéressant aussi de c'est avoir
le retour direct du transformateur sur
la qualité pour pouvoir réorienter la
production en fonction de l'heure de la
remarque
on a une soixantaine de vaches ont
produit 350 mille litres de lait par an
ont produit la même quantité de lait
qu'auparavant simplement aujourd'hui
entre les est produit dans des
conditions différentes
il respecte l'environnement et respecte
les animaux et respecte les gens qui
travaillent sur le site
et aussi les consommateurs avec un
produit de plus hautes valeurs mutati ve
le projet c'est bien que la totalité du
lait produit soit transformé par les
deux entreprises qui se sont installés
sur notre site le premier objectif c'est
donc bien de calais le système de qu' il
puisse se transformer la totalité du
lait il
on pense que dans les années à venir ils
ont une capacité plus importante des
débouchés plus important et nous on a
encore une marge au niveau de
l'exploitation pour augmenter un peu le
propos et produire un peu plus mais on
va forcément augmenter la production
individuelle
c'est une véritable filière locale qui
va de la production à la consommation
avec un effort particulier pour les
jeunes consommateurs dans les lycées et
pour cause si cette production est le
soient accessibles à tous
le bio n'est pas forcément un produit
qui est réservé à une certaine catégorie
de deux consommateurs mais aussi pour
l'ensemble des franciliens
quand on cherche à développer la
production et développer la production
biologique
il faut s'adresser aux jeunes le public
le public des jeunes est quand même un
public extrêmement important puisque ce
seront les 60 des consommateurs mais ce
seront des consommateurs demain ils vont
avoir une certaine venger de décision
pour choisir un produit je pense qu'il
est important aussi de les habituer à
manger ses produits il est aussi
important que les jeunes dans les écoles
apprennent aussi à reconnaître la
qualité des produits qui travaillent le
conte travail le goût et le l'intérêt
pour des produits vraiment de qualité
c'est un investissement pour l'avenir
c'est la force de ce sept huit invités
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]